you think it's easier for you to get
women than for me to get one yes that's
the system we've developed and it's also
easier for you to get food in America so
you came here so you have to put up with
that that's the sacrifice you make when
your family brings you here it's a
little harder to get laid but there's
food every day in the refrigerator right
it's a little bit harder there's food
every day and there's a refrigerator
that's just what it is it was funny but
I want to fight you no but it is funny
yeah
Gwyneth described you as not only just
cool but very cool how do you keep so
cool
air conditioner
I don't know even if you don't like the
Spice Girls you will be entertained this
is a question for all three of you what
is your favorite
Brad Pitt movie
it is a more expressive offer and see
and this next time you would think no
how could he look like this and here you
go there he is
now may I ask you one thing yes
someone has a lot of time on their hands
first thing you do when you wake up
first thing I do when I wake up I say
hey you all right
say what you do who are you interviewing
tonight oh you're interviewing me all
right I'll be right behind you what do I
keep with me every night in bed a your
husband because you Vlog yourself for
for being vulnerable oh would you stop
it like you have some sort of psychology
degree 10 years in therapy
football for 40 years I shouldn't be
somebody's coach
I agree but here I want you to know
something because uh she's a huge fan of
yours but there's an opening right now
for you because the top you're not the
top the top is always for my mom Daniel
Day-Lewis but I'm just saying if you
keep up your high quality work I feel
like you could hit that new Pinnacle for
my mom oh really yeah again just joking
always a physically appealing guy to you
a physically appealing guy to me yeah
is it I don't mind being typical like if
I said to you I could put you in a movie
with so and so who would it be I mean
honestly I'm like somebody who likes
like Gordon Ramsay I'm like the last
person Gordon Ramsay you're attracted to
him oh maybe I got a shot with you
Gordon Ramsay
you enjoy playing with Barbie dolls
not as much as I used to
what about shaving the eyebrow though I
mean what giving that idea I don't know
how I think it's just fat to go through
you know
dynamic
I wanted to put a tattoo if I would get
one there that would say buyer beware
and I can assure you that he knows there
is
all right
so your humor is a little
self-deprecating not really a little bit
a little bit yes a little bit is that
kind of your stick well you guys are
genetically uh one the genetic Lottery
you guys are beautiful people oh that's
very nice and I'm shaved like a scallop
so I have to do what I can you know I
mean I'm like oh fat or Pikachu
a little sneak attack you know like
Pearl Harbor
is that too soon is it too soon to do
Pearl Harbor jumps I'm so sorry I'm not
even Japanese I'm Korean so let's move
on thank you so much is there anything
you can't drive
how many different licenses do you have
I mean I have I have airplanes uh
commercial license Jets
a bunch of different airplanes
motorcycles parachutes boats
I have my real estate license
ask him if he had a rap name you didn't
ask me if I had a
rap name MC squared
hi
I'm Brian
I'm 60 and it's if you like threesomes
just remember
I like Malcolm in the Middle
[Applause]
that you like being on stage yeah yeah
there's lots of great stuff to do yeah
well okay first of all hopefully you
know you're you've finished a great job
you've done some great work you're
coming home you see some friends and
family you know hopefully you're in a
relationship you have some morning sex
eat a great breakfast go for a
motorcycle ride come back swim have more
sex
eats more hang out for a little bit
maybe do some reading you know go see a
movie have more sex
go to the bar have a couple of drinks
see some friends take a motorcycle ride
get home hang out a little bit have more
sex
um that's a pretty good day do you like
your ass
like it mm-hmm
I accept it okay
what is your favorite oh what is your
favorite swear word
yes no
hi
I'm Benedict but you can call me Big Ben
I'm
summer over 30.
if you're feeling a bit strange
the doctor will see you now
[Applause]
all right this is again across your
whole career what mementos have you
taken home and I love this question I'm
obsessed with it but what oh take him
back uh what did I take
um um I think I took the film
speaking of family Dwayne you also just
recently bought your mom a house
I did that like makes me want to cry
yeah no way no no no way
a billion dollars later
all right I think the whole room right
now is taking the same thing
thank you
Come a Little Closer
don't make me go too far
don't stop until it's over
is that flatter bubbly
it's a bunch of bourbon in here no it's
um it's flat because I thought like yo
mama oh
[ __ ] eight cups my man
I'm sorry I don't know where that came
your mom is she has huge breasts
problems very well endowed thank you
what is the strangest place you've
hooked up with someone a car trunk the
trunk of a car a trunk of a car that is
not
he's not serious there's no way enclosed
no I'm closed what you in the middle I
like your look yeah like a Spanish
soccer player thank you do you have a
very good comedian turned homeless look
going on I really enjoy it
okay
I look like a comedian homeless guy okay
thank you yes you know what I take that
back okay fair yeah you look like
Freddie Mercury okay look
on Master Chef Junior yes you're nice to
the kids because you're harsh you're
like an avenging angel on someone who
you think is not doing a good job but
how are you nice to these children if
you're such a mean terrible person or
most of the time that Bloody eight years
of age say what'd you expect yeah Wake
Up Get a Grip you'll use those pieces
because you can't talk like that to kids
what do you do that embarrasses your
kids
laughs exist
well first and foremost I'm terribly
sorry that I killed Peter sarsgaard
[ __ ]
right he deserved it
[ __ ] getting all this attention [ __ ]
him
I still have these outfits how would you
wear it today
I wouldn't
you say it's going to improve it's going
to improve the drugs so that we get to
use it I'm saying by the time we're 80
they're going to have like a steroid
vaporizer that you can just inhale and
you're going to have abs I'll get a full
head of hair and you're going to be
banging some hot 65 year old and it's
all going to be because of these
athletes and the sacrifices that they
make that no one appreciates have you
ever seen a script something and you
kind of think I'm not going to do that
actually you know what that sounds too
difficult too scary or have you just
everything's just gonna go nope let's do
it
is that for me yeah oh yeah sorry you're
happy talking to me
to play this opening on Friday it's
called waiting for Johnny Depp oh wow
and it's it's just it's a one woman did
everybody I've ever worked with right
if you could switch Powers with another
Avenger at which one would it be
it's a good one I I mean switching
Powers I take Vision not switching
makeup
it's a real nightmare but but the
ability alone yeah you can't you can't
beat Vision he has an infinity stone in
his head I don't know I don't know how
you top that Paul would you want to swap
with any more just stay Who You Are
yeah I'm okay where I am okay
yeah you know I mean
it might be nice to be Iron Man now and
again you know
but I'm pretty good where I am thank you
Jeremy
what